no  I think it's all yeah GTX F4 taken  gfgf and we're being told that grgf  castles is the computer suggestion and  the other one is Joe agreed what wow  detention  wow the tension and it means that we  will have an Armageddon deciding the  title that's insane  absolutely and one could feel that both  players were just too nervous in this  game  what  oh man I didn't know they must say draw  off her rule no draw for rules in this  tournament man who thought that it could  ever happen right I mean  wow  wow wow well I mean okay the whole point  is that we are not missing out on any  action because that's that's that's what  they're here for they're here they were  nice people they knew that we want to  also see the abdulsator of Magnus  Carlsen game and that their match they  wanted to feature it uniquely in their  Armageddon exactly it makes perfect  sense let's also then immediately switch  to